The joe rogan experience.
Well,
China,
China's on the side of North Korea.
That's part of the problem.
That's a part of our problem.
We can go,
she's still technically at war.
Most people don't know North Korea and South Korea.
Yeah,
they signed a cease fire.
They never signed an armistice.
Oh Wow.
So then there's no peace treaty.
They just will stop fighting for right now.
And it helps open a Hawaii the other day.
Yeah.
What the fuck man,
I fucking with us Kelly Slater's Instagram.
I was like,
what?
There was a fake nuclei or a fake missile warning that a missile was coming in
and they said it was not a drill.
Like how was that a wrong button kind of thing.
Like you must go through a few people before it goes out to the whole state and
you know how you getting a phone call and you have the other option.
Yeah,
exactly.
So like say,
Hey,
I'll call you back.
I'm driving.
You know,
like it's one of the two or three options that you could just press.
Yeah.
Is one of them.
Hey,
an intercontinental ballistic missiles heading your way.
Hawaii.
It's like,
oh,
here's the weather.
Here's missile,
and you hit the wrong.
No,
it shouldn't work that way.
Shouldn't be anywhere near like that.
Come on to the whole state.
So Stu Mcfarlane,
who was long,
her Instagram,
I was like,
yeah,
apparently is a missile.
It was the same shit.
I was unbelievable.
People were fucking crying and freaking out,
apparently.
Yeah.
I have a friend that lives in Hawaii.
You know that's a state that's been hit before.
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
Right.
So you gotta think mean memory of Pearl Harbor.
This is people who were alive back then.
Plenty of them.
Jeremy Mother fucking Steven's dom,
dom,
dom.
This should be war.
I am very excited about this.
Yeah.